( announcer )
You tried Slap Chef.
You tried Sleep Gym.
But now it's time to try
something that really works.
Introducing Sever Spine,
the new way to lose weight
by eliminating your
nervous system altogether.
By harnessing
the power of atrophy,
Sever Spine gets rid of all
those unwanted muscles.
I wanted to lose weight for
my high school reunion,
but I didn't
have a lot of time.
Thanks, Sever Spine.
How'd you like to get between
those two chopsticks, huh?
Take a number.
Are you one of the millions who
tried Slap Chef, Sleep Gym,
Sever Spine and suffered serious
injury or lost wages?
Hi, I'm Martin Davis
of the law offices
of Wakovy & Davis.
Our legal team specializes
in recovering monies
for innocent
victims like you.
Remember that fat ass?
Yuck.
Hi, I'm Martin Daniels.
My eating was out of control,
and exercise?
Forget it.
That is,
until I invented these.
Sit ‘Em Ups!
You can do these things
everywhere.
On the living room,
in front of a house,
in the bathroom during
a fancy dinner party.
It just seems like
a regular sit-up.
Well, it is!
Why do I need you
to tell me to do sit-ups?
Can't I just do sit-ups
and not pay you money?
Let me ask you something.
Before I said,
“Do sit-ups,”
were you thinking
about doing sit-ups?
No.
Then shut your fat mouth!
Sit ‘Em Ups! Order now!